hey Doug Walker here doing my quick
thoughts on the peanuts movie sadly Rob
couldn't see this one this week and I'm
even getting to it a little late but a
lot of people that asked me to see it
and what my thoughts on it are so uh
yeah here we go my um first thing I
should probably get across is what I
think of peanuts in general the comic
strip and the specials and everything I
like them a lot I don't think they're
like knee-slapping humor but I don't
think they're supposed to be I think
they're supposed to be a lot slower
paced they're supposed to be a little
bit more mellow and laid-back it's sort
of that awkward almost depressing
element of childhood but not quite
there's just enough happy stuff it's
kind of like that nice in-between I
really like that you don't see that much
in uh in kid shows or specials or
anything like that and I've seen a lot
of them I haven't seen all of them but
I've seen I've seen some of the movies
as in like you know sleepy come home and
bump oh yeah I Charlie Brown not because
we've seen the holiday specials and some
others so I really enjoyed them I like
them a lot so this movie comes along by
blue sky studios who I have not been a
very big fan of past years but they
always look Knight so you know the
movies always look very nice and they're
bright and colorful I just never get
into the humor or the stories or
anything like that and they seem a
little too desperate to me so I was a
little scared when I found out they're
gonna do a peanuts movie but then when I
saw the trailer and I saw can the
animation style it okay well maybe this
can wear maybe this can work
so this film comes out I go in and I see
it and it's good that that's if you want
just the clip know fast version it's
good um I don't think it's great but
with that said I will say that there's
there's kind of thought that all the
peanuts specials like anything
associated with the peanuts like is
either anywhere from phenomenal to at
the very worst okay and there's been
some bad ones I just started watching a
couple of them you know we we bought the
Halloween what you've got the Halloween
special on Amazon and they had a few of
their special
with it so you know my wife and I were
there let's watch a couple of these and
I was going through a few of them and
some of them are just really so good I
mean just freaking beautiful and then
others they could be really lame uh
there's one that was especially lame
called something along the lines of it's
magic Charlie Brown and the whole
episode like Charlie Brown gets turned
invisible and he's trying to figure out
how to not be invisible anymore
yeah pretty stupid it's like really
really stupid so this idea that the
peanuts can do no wrong and that there's
no bad specials that that's false but we
know what the penis specials are
supposed to be we look at the Halloween
one and the Christmas one some of these
movies and we say okay well we get the
idea what they're supposed to be like um
so this movie to its credit really tries
to get it and a lot of times it succeeds
um
they definitely have kind of the it's CG
but it's a good mix of kind of this I
don't want to say sloppy intentionally
choppy animation that's very much like
the hand-drawn animation that was very
very low-budget but it's very stylized
and they sort of mix it with some
hand-drawn stuff in there as well any
time someone's like thinking of
something or you know just imagining
something usually it's hand-drawn and
they tried to make it look like the
specials so if that was really cool um
and the littlest details that I was
really impressed they picked up on like
whenever Snoopy's flying is the Red
Baron you know he's on top of the house
he has the flying goggles on everything
shooting up and stuff like that even as
far as they go to make this animation
look really good a soaring through the
sky and all of her friends and stuff
like that they never show the bottom of
the house that is a good detail to pick
up and they shoot this from all sorts of
angles but no matter what you never see
the bottom of the doghouse as very very
clever and it's that kind of dedication
that makes it you know a little better
than just okay this was a cheap cash-in
but it isn't just the
the the strongest thing in this movie is
actually the writing the writing really
feels like classic traditional peanuts
it's a little slower pace there's no bad
guy there's no one big problem there's
no huge adventure they go on it's just
Charlie Brown kind of living his life
you see the little redhead girl come in
and he wants to impress her yeah if he
wants to get up the nerve just to go
talk to her and it's all the funny
little circumstances that happen around
that like that's it and I love movies
that can take something just that simple
and be like you know what that's enough
we don't need to go super crazy I
remember this is one episode and that
episode was a movie um it was something
like run for your life Charlie Brown or
something like that we enters like a
rafting competition and they got the big
bad bullies who every single turn they
tried to sabotage them and it's like I
hate that and they don't do that
here they just show a little bit of
Charlie Brown's life they sort of show
him from like you know the beginning of
winter to the end of summer you know and
that's it um and that's great and I'm
this movie could have been so much worse
it could have been so bad just seeing
what they've done with like the Lorax
and stuff like that I'm pretty sure
blues guy right um did not no no no it
wasn't it wasn't that was the the
despicable me people I'm so sorry but
this guy hasn't done that much great
stuff but but that's my point they could
have taken this a really bad direction
and updated too much but it was a good
mix it's still CG animation but the CG
looks really nice the colors are really
Pleasant the minute it opens up on this
winter background you know the snow is
falling but it's like a blue blue sky
which you don't see much in movies and
then for good reason you don't see much
of real life but it looks really nice um
but they still have kind of the hand
drawn eyes and mouths and stuff like
that so uh so that's all great the one
problem I have with this movie and it's
not a nitpick but it's it's not it
doesn't ruin anything but but I think it
is a problem sort of stops this from
being like really great is the the slap
sticks a little too much this is one of
the few times where I actually thought
to myself I wish this movie was slower
it's so rare that I say that you know a
lot of times it's like all of the
fast-paced is wonderful I just gets to
the meat of the subject really quick but
peanuts was kind of about these little
moment these little slow awkward moments
and it's not that they never captured
that it's that they constantly want to
show a lot of the stuff they usually
just belong to Snoopy and whenever it's
new peas on screen he's jumping around
he's dance and he's doing slapstick he's
doing all this crazy stuff as Snoopy
should but all the characters are kind
of doing that and I'm thinking to myself
that's not needed what what mades
peanuts so funny in their slapstick is
that it was usually slower and it was
usually a little bit more laid-back so
that when the really silly physical
stuff happened it got a bigger laugh
like there's a lot of scenes in here I
was saying to myself you know if they
played that a little slower I would have
laughed a little more but instead it's
just like oh that's just one physical
joke on top of 20 others they're
throwing at you so that was a little bit
of a problem and I think the pace in
general was a hint to fast there's a lot
of scenes that feel like Schulz comic
strips I found out I figured out how
they can save by Schultz because I'm
like isn't he dead it's the family
members they're continuing it but that
wrote it so that's very clever but they
capture the voice very well and it's
something where you it's not quite like
you know run for your life Charlie Brown
or you know come home Snoopy or
something like that where they have to
tell a completely new story that whole
times oh and it's the peanuts movie and
it's a new kind of animation and it's a
somewhat different style not much but
they they want to recapture the feel of
the peanuts in the peanuts movie you
want to look at this and say oh that was
the peanuts that's what they're all
about that's what they do so you have to
sort of do this all-encompassing feature
that for the most part succeeds it gets
the
it gets a lot of the story the awkward
is it gets the charm it gets the color
it gets the artistic look of it it gets
the simplicity the only thing I say it's
missing a little bit of not that's
totally devoid of it uh it could have
used a little bit more weight a little
bit more of the heavy moments um which
is tough to do for peanuts because
peanuts is not hit you on the head
obvious I know a lot of people think it
is you'll go like the Christmas special
it's like what you can't get more
obvious than that but there is just
serve this unspoken strangeness and this
atmosphere when you watch a lot of the
specials and you realize like yeah it's
not not everything's just spelled out I
mean this is a kid who's like he's
likable and he's you know and you wanted
to succeed but he will never succeed
that's always the running joke and
that's really a downer cuz there's
really nothing wrong with this kid it's
like the universe has just conspired
against this one boy and that's really a
downer idea for something that's
supposed to be you know so simplistic
and upbeat and innocent so it's tough
and you you could make a little bit of
the argument that the ending is a little
bit of a cop-out I'm I'm on the fence
about it because my thought is like if
you want to see a special or a movie or
whatever where bad stuff still happens
to Charlie Brown you have tons there's a
lot of them if you want one we're just
hey things finally kind of go is wave
finally he gets kind of the happy ending
this is one to watch although even then
if you watch the credits you know some
things still don't go his way so it's
it's a good enough balance for me but
yeah I think some people will be a
little pissed off that like they that
the ending almost seems a little too
happy I don't think I'm giving anything
away by saying there's you know kind of
a happy ending you know it's a kid's
film but yeah might be a little too
happy and I also really want to say
thank you for making this a G movie
freaking everything nowadays is like the
lowest rate that you can have as a PG
you know this used to happen in the 90s
all the time we're just
oh well we can't make it a G because
that means to be crap only Disney could
do that and that's it everything else is
crap but then Pixar came along and
started to make G films that were really
good and people didn't care about the
ratings it's like oh let's go
but now Pixar is making them PG and I'm
trying to think in these films like what
what was even worth the PG rating in
them like I can't think of anything
inside out or anything like that but
they they gotta put it in cuz it's like
oh the thing G is you know - safer or
not funny or not risque Reggie you know
and that's that's a shame um so I'm glad
this movie did well and it kept the G
rating it didn't friggin go dr. Susan be
like oh well be these always have to be
PG cuz it's dr. Seuss we always need
parental guidance when it comes to Seuss
so I'm glad they said its peanuts we're
gonna keep it simple we're gonna keep it
nice we're gonna keep it for kids but
adults can watch it too uh so yeah I
really enjoyed it I think the like I
said the only thing you could use more
of it could've been a little slower and
I think it could used a little bit more
weight to it um I still think something
like Snoopy comes home is you know it's
gonna be come up with a lot heavier uh
you know I mean there's legitimately sad
sad moments in there where this has kept
a lot more upbeat but there's still the
traditional stuff you want to see you
kinda wanna see Charlie Brown have bad
things happen to um you kinda wanna see
stuff not go his way um but not to an
abusive play so yeah I liked it I I
didn't love it necessarily but I thought
for a CG adaptation of Charlie Brown
this is pretty well done and yeah I
think that's about it I think you can
get an idea whether you would enjoy it
or not and how much of the spirit of the
peanuts it captures and you know if
that's your thing or not so uh that's
about it and I will see you around later